the day is finally here today is the end
of the donald trump era it is the start
of the presidency
of joe biden who will be or has already
been sworn in by the time you listen to
today's show by the time you watch this
clip
it has felt like so long and at the same
time it feels like just yesterday that i
was watching those numbers come in from
florida
at 7 25 pm eastern time in november of
2016 and thinking this isn't looking
quite so good for hillary clinton
but we've talked about all that and
today is the day where trump out
biden in and finally
the beginning of getting beyond the
global historic
nightmare that has been the trump
administration but donald trump did not
leave quietly yes he was quiet on
twitter because he was suspended
yes we didn't see any live press
conference or speech from donald trump
in the lead-up to his final days but
trump was never going to leave totally
quietly and he delivered yesterday a
deranged and meandering screed
of a speech we will look only at a few
clips today we are all
so glad to be getting beyond this but
it's important to know what were the
last utterances
to slip from trump's mouth the theme
yesterday
in this pre-recorded speech the theme
was trump taking credit for really
anything that he could even just general
delusions of grandeur
like this one with the support and
prayers of the american people
we achieved more than anyone thought
possible nobody thought we could even
come
close of course whatever achievements
you think did take place during this
trump administration historically will
be outweighed
dramatically by the massive overwhelming
failures of the administration
on everything in particular on covid
on global relations on climate and i
could go on and as i've said before
had trump properly handled the virus
response
it would be trump being sworn in for
four more years today
not joe biden we saw it happen in other
countries
and that was trump's undoing he couldn't
control
that he had to deal with the virus
nobody could
but proper handling of the virus did
lead to
re-elections for leaders that handled it
correctly
trump wildly and incorrectly claiming
that
now the world respects us and warns that
we should avoid losing the respect
he believes or claims to have secured
for the united states
completely delusional and we know we
know that for a fact take a look
the world respects us again please
don't lose that respect so this
has been widely studied we don't have to
speculate
we don't have to guess we don't need
conjecture
respect for the united states around the
world absolutely in the toilet
you know those toilets trump says he you
know would have to flush 10 or 15 times
if joe biden's environmental regulations
get in well
that's where the global reputation is
for the united states in the toilet
and the challenge will actually be the
opposite of what donald trump says it
will be
ken joe biden restore respect for the
united states with trump gone
what countries are willing to say okay
let's let's reestablish mutual trust and
respect
after trump is gone i think many
countries will be willing to do that
uh because it matters that uh we
re-establish those alliances it matters
for them as much as it matters for us
but no trump
with with opposite opposite day speech
the respect was lost
under trump trump also interestingly
saying he deliberately chose the tough
battles rather than taking the easy path
he sort of framed during this
pre-recorded uh speech that was released
yesterday
he said you know par part of what made
his administ his presidency tough was he
chose to do the tough things sort of uh
um an illusion in some sense to john f
kennedy but failing miserably to make
any kind of analogy
as president my top priority my constant
concern
has always been the best interests of
american workers and american families
i did not seek the easiest course by far
it was actually
the most i took on the tough battles the
hardest fights
the most difficult choices because
that's what you
elected me to do your needs were my
first and last
unyielding focus this i hope will be
our greatest legacy this one is
interesting because in a way it's sort
of a positive moment he's not attacking
anyone necessarily not directly anyway
but it's also very disconnected from
reality he actually chose
easy things and messed them up and he
also messed up things
that every president has to deal with
and he also messed up things that every
world leader was presented with and
dealt with better than trump coronavirus
of course being
at the top of that list trump did say
and i think this is the closest
i've ever heard trump be to conciliatory
in any way
trump said he is praying for the success
of the next administration but there's a
little weird tweak he adds in there that
i want to talk about
this week we inaugurate a new
administration
and pray for its success in keeping
america safe
and prosperous we extend our best wishes
and we also want them to have luck a
very
important word trump has to add
something
snarky or weird and it's trump
mentioning
luck and this is a reference to
trump seeing himself as having had bad
luck that he had to deal with the
coronavirus pandemic
but more importantly trump didn't even
mention
joe biden in this 20-minute speech trump
mentions the next administration
as he did in these vague terms about
eight to ten days ago
but he never says joe biden and he
didn't say it today in another a final
screed that we will get to
and it is another one of these signals
about the petulant child
that is donald trump now it is true that
without trump's mishandling of the
pandemic he would have been re-elected i
talked about that moments ago
but trump handling the pandemic well is
not a question of
luck it's just a question of who was
determined to do it and who was capable
of doing it as we saw many world leaders
do
the bad luck was actually for us the bad
luck was for the world
that we were so unlucky that it was
trump in power
when the global hundred year pandemic
hit just about anyone else
including just you know a high school
science teacher any like anybody who
would have just said oh this is a
situation where we need experts let's
defer to them from day one
would have worked out better than having
trump in power that's bad luck for us it
wasn't trump's bad luck
uh trump wrapping up the end of uh this
uh pre-recorded speech
by taking a page out of kimberly
guilfoyle's playbook
remember from the republican national
convention the best
is yet to come you remember that here's
trump
using that phrase i go from this
majestic
place with a loyal and joyful heart
and optimistic spirit and a supreme
confidence that
for our country and for our children
the best is yet to come thank you
and farewell god bless you god bless
the united states of america so another
lame
speech to cap off a lame failed
presidency that we are
thrilled to see finally over and notice
that in this entire speech trump didn't
mention joe biden as i said
earlier he completely glossed over 400
000 coronavirus deaths
although he mentioned that this morning
he glosses over the pro-trump riots that
he inspired at the capitol two weeks ago
and the
militarized state of the city as trump
leaves thanks to him and it is yet
another pathetic joke now
one little extra goodbye on his way out
trump revoked the executive order that
banned administration officials from
becoming lobbyists within five years of
leaving government
drain the swamp right my friends and
that's something that really should be
codified into law rather than left up to
administrations
uh we will be covering the inauguration
but first trump's
final weird sort of rally like goodbye
happened this morning let's talk about
that next
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night even on a full stomach
since it's chewable
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet package
they're made in the usa and since
bluetooth prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-chew.com
promo code pacman to try it totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show